if you're a fairly oddparents fan you're
going to love this get ready to find out
the most inappropriate episodes from
this hit Nickelodeon show number one is
definitely the most jaw-dropping so
stick around to the end to see it for
yourself if Timmy were here right now he
would definitely wish for you to
subscribe to this channel and like this
video so grant his wish already and
let's get on with the 10 fairly
oddparents episodes that weren't for
kids hide my parents and my nuts no one
loves a good double entendre more than
we do but this episode takes this to a
whole new level in the episode titled
meet the odd parents Timmy's parents
find out that Timmy has fairly
godparents named Wanda and Cosmo they
are actually pretty cool about it
Timmy's mom offers to make the fairy
some brownies and lemonade since they
are magical fairies they make brownies
and lemonade instantly appear with a
wave of their wands Timmy's parents
enjoy lemonade in brownies with Timmy's
fairy godparents but Timmy's dad says he
prefers nuts in his treats Cosmo agrees
and adds nuts the only problem is
according to the fairy rule book named
dolls if anyone finds out that Timmy has
these fairy godparents a fairy named
Jorgen will come and take them away when
they find out Jorgen is coming to lay
down the fairy law timmy tells Wanda and
Cosmo to hide his parents Timmy yells
hide my parents then Timmy's dad yells
and my nuts he's talking about the nuts
in the lemonade and the brownies right
this episode is loaded with enough nut
jokes to make a squirrel laugh for days
luckily this joke will go over the heads
of the younger viewers vandalism playing
hooky and disrespecting the law in the
episode go young Westman timmy and cat
kid played by Adam West ditched school
to go to the arcade and the ice cream
parlor if you're a parent trying to keep
your kids from skipping class you may
want to skip this episode to make
matters worse Timmy and cat kid TP mr.
Crocker's house that's right they cover
the house in toilet paper hey kids if
you're into truancy and vandalism this
is the show for you
and let's not forget a general
disrespect for authority figures like
truant officer shallow grave who is
portrayed as a scary one-eyed villain
with the claw for a hand
he tries to get his fairy godparents to
hit this officer of the government with
a train a bus or a car Wanda and Cosmo
quickly scanned the rules in the book
called de rules that they must follow
when granting wishes as it turns out the
rules say they aren't allowed to grant
Timmy's wish to commit vehicular
manslaughter so they say no but clever
Timmy finally gets them to agree with
his truant officer shallow grave with a
clown on a unicycle isn't that funny
yes it's absolutely hilarious is it
appropriate for children probably not
Timmy's dad admits his dreams were
shattered when he had to me most parents
find the birth of their children to be a
dream come true but that's not the case
with Timmy's parents anyone who watches
the show can see that Timmy's parents
are neglectful and they often make jokes
at Timmy's expense so it's not out of
character for Timmy's dad to admit that
his dreams were shattered when Timmy was
born in this episode timmy sees his
mother's Hope Chest it's covered in
cobwebs and dust on top of the Hope
Chest is a little blue box when Timmy
asks what it is Dada replies that's my
tiny box of Dreams the box slips out of
Timmy's hands and shatters on the floor
he immediately apologizes Timmy's dad
says oh don't worry about it Timmy my
dreams were shattered years ago
Timmy asks how many years ago his dad
replies with how old are you this joke
implies that Timmy destroyed his mother
and father's hopes and dreams the day he
was born
that'll be a few thousand dollars in
therapy one day yeh psychological abuse
kids watching this episode we'll learn
the age-old skill of cutting remarks and
cruel jokes good times
are you bad parents in poof's playdate
Timmy's parents watched the dr. bill
show in which dr. bill gives thee are
you bad parents quiz meanwhile Timmy is
throwing a pancake party for poo he
invites the fairies from fairyland to
come but decides it would be more fun
for poof if he wishes they were all
babies needless to say fairy babies can
get pretty messy there are massive
amounts of pancake syrup and other
substances all over Timmy's room and
Timmy gets no help from his baby fairy
godparents so this is one mess Timmy has
tickly
himself back to dr. villas parent test
dr. bill asks does your despondent child
say I'm busy a lot right away Timmy runs
through the house and yells I'm busy
then dr. bill asks do they use a lot of
paper towels spend too much time alone
in their rooms and say don't bother me
then Timmy runs in and says I'm just
gonna take these paper towels up to my
room alone so don't bother me if you
don't get how this joke is inappropriate
for kids then you've never heard of a
pubescent teenage boy but hey at least
he's cleaning up after himself right
Timmy's fairy godparents make mean jokes
at Timmy's expense this kid can't catch
a break first he's got neglectful
parents and an abusive babysitter and
now even his fairy godparents are making
mean jokes at Timmy's expense sure the
kid is far from perfect he could use
even one of his wishes to cure cancer or
even world hunger and instead he wishes
for accordion playing dinosaurs but he
still deserves a bit of kindness doesn't
he in The Fairly OddParents
episode titled superbike Timmy's dad
makes him a bike for the annual
dimmsdale father-son bike race let's
just say this bike is interesting no
surprise here Timmy's dad routinely
disappoints his son but imagine our
surprise when Wanda and Cosmo take a
crack at Timmy's self-worth with this
humdinger Timmy says the bike stinks and
that he needs a bike that's as cool as
he is
- which Cosmo replies Timmy this bike is
as cool as you are
ouch not cool it's certainly not the
best thing in the world for children to
watch parents'll figures chip away at a
kid's self-worth
not to worry children Timmy can just
wish for more self-esteem right Tom
Sawyer takes over the galaxy in this
episode Timmy wishes for Tom Sawyer out
of his book so he can help him write a
book report much to everyone's surprise
Tom steals cosmos blonde and causes
major chaos in the literary universe
Timmy Wanda and Cosmo chase Tom through
book after book and how they wind up in
astrophysics for morons Wanda and Cosmo
realized the severity of the situation
when Timmy explains all of the dreadful
consequences that could result from Tom
taking over the galaxy
Timmy explains that Tom could turn
gravity into gravy and turn all the
planets into plants
Wanda concludes that Tom could turn
Uranus into Oh
my gosh we've got to stop him and there
it is ladies and gentlemen the one
billionth time a year anus joke has been
told this calls for a celebration
seriously though we feel for this planet
whose name is widely mocked and
ridiculed it must feel terrible to be
the butt of all the jokes there you have
it ladies and gentlemen 1 billion in one
year anus jokes we wish we had prepared
a speech any kid who has studied the
solar system in school has giggled when
the planet is called out by name but is
still another example of juvenile and
inappropriate humor Cosmo gets plastic
surgery in the episode titled this is
your wish Kosmos mother played all the
ways her son has messed up
Timmy's wishes in an attempt to get
Cosmo to move back home with her she
replays a clip of Cosmo saving Timmy
from a train only to leave him tied up
to a portion of the tracks that are
sinking in quicksand she goes on to show
Cosmo giving Timmy a big hungry spider
when what he really wished for was a big
glass of cider when Timmy wishes for a
lawnmower Cosmo conjures up a
flamethrower and toast Wanda with it but
perhaps the biggest club of Kosmos
journey was when he gave himself plastic
surgery
Timmy falls on the floor laughing while
Cosmo declares that he is keeping the
new figure this joke is clearly not
geared toward children who probably
don't even know what plastic surgery is
but a knocker joke in a kid's cartoon
how did they get away with that one way
to slip that one by the sensors guys
we're with Timmy that's got us rofl you
know rolling on the floor laughing nice
bigger Cosmo do you think you should
keep them to campaign with Timmy's
father what could go wrong so by now we
all get that Timmy's father is not the
best dad in the world but they may take
that joke a bit too far with this
episode Timmy's dad wants to take Timmy
on a camping trip to faultline National
Park Timmy expresses his concern to his
fairy godparents that every time and dad
takes he and his friends camping he
always puts them in terrible danger
the poster alone for the destination
campground is downright disturbing
it features an erupting volcano and
campers running away screaming in horror
he also tells Timmy to worry about the
vicious inbred mountain men rather than
the earthquakes cue the nightmares
kiddos but do the inappropriate jokes
stop there
No and if all that wasn't bad enough
good old dad makes a joke that's in
pretty poor taste even for this show he
says if I Drive a group of boys to the
movies in this outfit they'll arrest me
we just hope this joke went the way of
the smoke from that threatening volcano
and flew over kids heads this cartoon is
intended for children isn't it okay just
checking
cyberbullying and inappropriate internet
videos so this episode is pretty odd
even buying Fairly OddParents standards
timmy tries to send an email to his love
interest Trixie
but the fairy godparents encouraged to
me to be less mushy and more threatening
Cosmo takes over Timmy's email and
writes dear Trixie we have your parents
if you ever want to see them again
that's one heck of a message to send to
young people if you like a girl just
threaten her and she will be all yours
seriously kids that's not a good idea
and to make matters worse Timmy's
parents double down on this off-color
joke by saying that's how Timmy's dad
met his mother and then they laugh and
laugh and laugh as if dating weren't
confusing enough then at the end of the
episode Timmy's dad walks in and sees
mr. Crocker in a dress on Timmy's
computer he makes another knee-slapping
joke he says Timmy you're not supposed
to be on those kinds of websites when
Timmy explains that is his teacher his
dad says the dress does make mr. Crocker
look pretty while joking about websites
that are unsuitable for children it's
important to button it up with a nice
compliment you had us at pretty and red
is definitely mr. Crocker's color Kosmos
ChaCha's in the episode Anchors Away
Cosmo is wearing a hoop skirt in the
desert when Wanda criticizes him for it
he defends his odd fashion choice by
saying it complements my ChaCha's he
then pulls out a pair of maracas and
shakes them but we know what he really
meant later when a fox attacks Cosmo he
says I probably shouldn't have filled my
ChaCha's with meat this surely had all
the teenagers in the land snickering how
did he get away with this stuff but
perhaps the most blatant of the cha-cha
jokes was the one where Timmy Cosmo
Wanda and food take a journey to the
outskirts of town this episode is all
about the clever play on words for
example when Timmy says he loves the
outskirts of town
Cosmo who is now donning a pink skirt
replies yeah they sell the best
it's out here can we go to the out
boxershorts of town next because I'm
totally flying off fresco under my skirt
now we all know that all fresco means
out in the fresh air so thanks for the
TMI Cosmo I'm sure all kids everywhere
wanted to know if your beans were
blowing in the breeze that's it for our
10 fairly oddparents episodes that
weren't for kids we hope you had as many
laughs as we did what was your favorite
inappropriate moment be sure to comment
below later dudes
[Music]